ES REPORTIPLE IN THE FEDERAL RNG
S
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS CONFRONTEE
AR
.
HODOOU DO NO
OUR IT, FINEYOU HAH THIS COV
N OPPONENT OF F HE SIN
SEE HIM ASK E KIDS TO
JOHN. VIDEO
ONLINE WAS SWIFT.
STE CRITICIZING THE GOVERNOR.IA
IS RUNNI CULTURE
GOVERN DeSANTIS  A
BULLY.CHSTN TWITTER THE GOVEOR.
SAID, PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE E TREATED WITH
RESPECT, NOT DUMPED ON B
S EGOTISTICAOR
SAG PROPONENT OF MASGOVERNOR HA
FREEDOM AND HE HAS BEEN ONE OF
AND A LOT OFPLE ARE SAYING, AS
DeISRYING TO TAKAW
PEOPLE THI
SITUATIO
THERA T  REASONS WHYK
NOW.
RECOMMENDS PEOPLE WEAR INDOORS
L HIGH RISK OF HERE.E GOVERNOR
INCREASINGLY MASK CHOICE BUT
LA WEE GAVE
GUIDANCE TO BUSINESSES
ACROSS THET SAID THEY OULD NLON.
STIS OFFICWITHAT T
STUDENTS -- TT KT GIVING THESE